Some people use the
letters FOIL as a strategy
for making sure they have
multiplied all the terms.
Use the FOIL
approach to multiply
3x plus 2 times 5x minus 7.
I'm actually not
one of those people
who likes to use
the FOIL letters,
because it's just a
form of memorization
as opposed to realizing
that you're just
using the distributive
property twice.
But with that said,
let's actually
use FOIL so you see
that it actually
is the same thing as using the
distributive property twice.
So just to remember
FOIL, it literally stands
for-- so F-O-I-L. The F
in FOIL stands for First.
The O stands for Outside.
The I stands for Inside.
And the L stands for Last.
So not only do you
have to remember FOIL,
you have to remember what
each of these letters
actually stand for.
But let's see how that applies
to multiplying these two
binomials.
So we have 3x plus
2 times 5x minus 7.
So we're starting
with the first,
we're starting with the F.
We have to multiply the first
terms in each of the binomials.
So that's going
to be 3x times 5x.
Then we do the outside terms.
So that's going to be the
3x times the negative 7.
So this is going to be
plus 3x times negative 7.
Then we want to do
the inside terms.
Then we want to do-- I'll
do that in green-- then
we want to do the inside terms.
So that's the 2 and the 5x.
So that's plus 2 times 5x.
And then we want to
do the last terms.
And the last terms are
the 2 and the negative 7,
so plus 2 times negative 7.
And we end up getting 3x times
5x is 15x squared, plus--
or I should say
minus because there's
going to be a
negative sign here.
So 3x times negative
7 is negative 21x.
And then we have 2
times 5x is-- let
me do that in that
same shade of green.
So this is plus 10x.
And then 2 times negative
7 is negative 14,
or now it's minus 14.
And we can add these two
middle terms together.
If we have negative 21x and
then we add 10x to that,
that gives us negative 11x.
So this right here
is negative 11x.
And then these other
terms over here.
We have 15x squared
minus 11x minus 14.
So we just used FOIL.
What I want to do
is show you this
is the same thing as applying
the distributive property
twice.
So if we have-- I'll
rewrite the problem-- 3x
plus 2 times 5x minus 7.
What we could do is
distribute the 5x minus 7.
We can multiply
that times the 3x.
And we could also
multiply that--
and let me make it
clear when I say
that, I mean this whole 5x minus
7-- we can multiply it times
the 3x and by the 2.
We're just distributing
it over the 3x plus 2.
So we get literally
3x times 5x minus 7
plus 2 times 5x minus 7.
And then this gives us 3x times
5x is going to be 15x squared.
3x times negative 7 is
going to be negative 21x.
And remember, in
this step we're just
applying the distributive
property again.
So then we have 2 times 5x is
going to be 10x, so plus 10x.
And then we have 2 times
negative 7 is negative 14.
So we actually got
the exact same result
that we did when
we applied FOIL.
And when you simplify it
you get this answer again.